freunde der sonne freund innen der sonne
das hier ist ein etwas anderes video und
ich hoffe ihr gebt ihm trotzdem eine
chance denn seinerzeit beschäftigt mich
eine frage und ich hoffe dass ich diese
frage nach diesem video bzw
nach euren kommentaren in diesem besser
für mich selbst beantworten kann um
diese frage lautet sollte man ändern
sollte man was sollte ich wenn ich über
wissenschaftler rede lieber über
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
reden oder über wissenschaftler innen
und bevor ihr jetzt denkt was für eine
social justice keine sorge dass wir
jetzt eine rationale abhandlung also ich
möchte in diesem video fertig machen ich
möchte zuerst erklären warum diese frage
überhaupt wichtig ist dann möchte ich
argumente für und gegen sondern auch
führen wozu mich auf eure meinung
interessiert und am ende habe ich eine
art n1 mit wie sagt man dazu einen
aufruf an euch und zwar jetzt kein
aufruf einen kommentar zu schreiben oder
dieses video zu leiten weil sie
natürlich trotzdem machen könnt sondern
eher als dass ich aber eins nach dem
anderen
setzt euch warum mache ich mir überhaupt
gedanken über das gender ich fand in der
schule mathe gut ich war
naturwissenschaften gut ich hab ich
finde ich mein studium entschieden
ich habe danach aber promoviert und bei
alldem hat mein geschlecht in meinem
kopf keine rolle gespielt wann immer ich
das wort chemiker gehört habe habe ich
jetzt nie gedacht chemiker sondern
chemiker ich sage sogar manchmal ich bin
chemiker stadt ich bin chemikerin als
jetzt ohne groß darüber nachzudenken ich
habe mir nie gedanken gemacht wie
schaffe ich ein chemiestudium oder ein
physikstudium oder ein maschinenbau
studium als mädchen oder frau also zum
glück habe ich mir diese gedanken
gemacht sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich
eine chemikerin geworden weil ich damals
eben auch noch nicht so selbstbewusst
war wie heute wie es halt so ist wenn
man jünger ist noch bis zum ende meiner
doktorarbeit hätte ich es niemals in
erwägung gezogen bei dem vortrag oder so
zu gendern also wenn ich von chemikern
oder wissenschaftlern oder kollegen
und wenn mich jemand gebeten hätte doch
auch mal die chemikerinnen und so weiter
explizit anzusprechen hätte ich
wahrscheinlich gesagt warum weiß doch
jeder was gemeint ist und wenn jemand
gesagt hätte dass ich mal ein ganzes
video zu diesem thema machen würde dann
hätte ich wahrscheinlich gesagt nein
sorry aber ich hab echt andere probleme
meine persönliche wahrnehmung hat sich
nicht geändert aber mein beruf hat sich
geändert ich bin jetzt keine
wissenschaftlerin mehr sondern
wissenschaftsjournalistin und
wissenschaftskommunikatoren also früher
waren heizplatte und speichel meine
werkzeuge
heute ist es sprache so und sprache ist
für viele naturwissenschaftler bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla also wir
naturwissenschaftler ist die einzig
sinnvolle sprache fachsprache die
sachlich und klar definiert ist deswegen
fällt es gerade naturwissenschaftlern
oft schwer andere menschen zu erreichen
um zu bewegen weil normale sprache im
gegensatz zur fachsprache viel mehr
ebenen und bedeutungen hat dadurch ist
sprache genial und glücklich zugleich
denn sie beeinflusst unsere wahrnehmung
ganz stark wer das nicht glaubt muss ich
mal nur unsere videos anschaut deswegen
sich sämtliche sprachlichen fragen
darunter auch die frage nach dem gender
auch ziemlich technisch denn wie kann
ich meine sprache möglichst gut
einsetzen um das zu erreichen was ich
möchte und was ich erreichen möchte ist
wissenschaft vermitteln an möglichst
viele menschen das ist mein beruf das
ist auch meine leidenschaft und deswegen
ist sprach mit all ihren kleinen nuancen
die für manche vielleicht so ein
bisschen nach pillepalle king für mich
sehr wichtig geworden so was spricht
jetzt für gender und was dagegen ich
möchte jetzt einen kleinen
schlagabtausch mit mir selbst machen
chrome ein mann sollte gender gegen
kontron nein nein und ihr könnt die jury
sein los geht's
argument nummer eins ländern ist gute
kommunikation lange zeit hatte ich
relativ wenig zuschauer innen doch je
mehr freunde der sonne und freundinnen
der sonne hier hinzu kam dass die öfter
begegnete ich menschen so in den
kommentaren als auch in nachrichten als
real life die mir sagten dass sie es
schön finden wenn ich ändern würde und
die mir das auch sehr respektvoll und
verständnisvoll erklärten ich treffe
mädchen und junge frauen die wir sagen
dass sie sich ernsthaft nicht
angesprochen fühlen wenn ich jetzt von
chemikern oder wissenschaftlern rede ich
vertrete das credo kommunikation ist
nicht das was du sagst oder meinst
sondern nur das was beim anderen ankommt
das heißt wer nicht dazu bereit ist sich
in sein publikum hinein zu versetzen der
kann kein guter kommunikator oder keine
gute kommunikatorin und wenn ich die
sorgen meiner zuschauer in nicht ernst
nehme und in jedem wissenschaftler
chemiker und physiker was ich sage
mädchen und frauen ausschließe die
dadurch ganz subtil den eindruck
vermittelt bekommen dass wissenschaftler
meistens männer sind dann wäre das sehr
sehr schade argument 1 ländern ist
schlechte kommunikation der sehr gute
wissenschaftskommunikatoren liegt sagt
sehr schön
kommunikation ist nie neutral sie ist
immer eins von zwei sachen nämlich
entweder signal oder neues entweder
signal oder rauschen alles was du
eigentlich vermitteln willst ist signal
und alles was kein signal ist ist
rauschen also störung ablenkung ein
guter text enthält demnach keine
füllwörter die keinen zweck erfüllen die
diese füllwörter sind raus sie
verschlechtern die signal to noise race
sowie wissenschaftler gerne sagen wenn
ich jetzt über impfen rede dann ist das
geschlecht der wissenschaftler keine
relevante info demnach ist es kein
signal sondern raus sie lenkt ab vor
allem wenn es in den ohren fehler häufig
klingt dann fanden die wissenschaftler
innen folgendes soll hier
ich dachte du hättest dich verschluckt
und auch wenn ich stattdessen seine
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
oder noch besser
naturwissenschaftlerinnen und
naturwissenschaftler
dann wird das sehr lang und nimmt
dadurch automatisch in meinem satz
gewicht ein obwohl es ja innerlich keine
große rolle spielen sollte weil man
natürlich einräumen muss dass es vor
allem ablenkt weil wir es nicht gewohnt
sind
wissenschaftler innen zu hören und wenn
das aber jeder so sagen würde und siehe
da nicht anders kennen würde dann hätten
wir dieses kommunikationsprobleme und
nicht pro grund zwei sprachliches
repräsentieren man könnte jetzt sagen
wie unwichtig sind so kleine endungen
wie innen wer wir doch über wirklich
wichtige dinge wie wissenschaft sprechen
einerseits stimmt das natürlich
andererseits sind kleine oberflächliche
dinge nun einmal wichtig ob wir es
wollen oder nicht es sollte ja auch
keine rolle spielen wir hier gerade vor
der kamera sitzt denn auf diesem kanal
geht es um inhalte und trotzdem spielt
es natürlich eine rolle wie ich aussehe
und ob ihr mich sympathisch findet oder
ob ihr euch vielleicht eben ihr
identifizieren könnte es sollte keine
rolle spielen wenn wir über wissenschaft
reden
aber zu glauben dass es in der realität
in der praxis tatsächlich keine rolle
spielt das zu glauben wäre naiv und auch
wenn ich den eindruck habe dass unsere
community da viel offener ist so ist der
ganze mint bereich mint steht für
mathematik naturwissenschaften technik
so ist dieser ganze bereich in unserer
gesellschaft immer noch sehr stereotyp
ish männlich ich persönlich kenne privat
sehr viele naturwissenschaftlerinnen und
ingenieurinnen und informatikerin also
fast alle meine engen freundinnen sind
mittlerin aber ich sehe sie nicht in den
medien oder hier auf youtube also in
youtube deutschland bin ich als
weibliches gesicht für einen windkanal
so ziemlich alleine ich meine schaut
doch einfach mal die you tube trends die
geschlechterstereotypen sind da extrem
starke also mädels machen beauty und
jungs machen gamings sollte sich das
nicht ändern ich werde gar nicht
erzwingen was jetzt völlig unnatürlich
ist ich finde es einfach nur krass wie
sich meine realität mit all den coolen
wissenschaftlerinnen die ich kenne so
komplett unterscheidet von dieser
seltsam wählt die wir hier auf youtube
sehen und als erwachsene frau mit einem
inzwischen auch ausreichend
selbstbewusstsein und so weiter kann ich
das ganze ja auch aus der distanz
analysieren und einordnen
aber hier schauen ja auch ganz viele
junge zuschauerinnen zu die sich durch
diese geschlechterstereotypen auch sehr
stark beeinflussen lassen so gesehen
finde ich es schön chemikerinnen
ingenieurinnen informatikerinnen
wenigstens sprachlich sichtbar zu machen
wenn sie sonst schon so unsichtbar sind
gegenargument zwei nicht sprachliches
repräsentieren mint sollte nichts mehr
geschlecht zu tun haben warum betonen
wir also sprachlich dass man sein oder
frau sein wenn es doch eigentlich gar
keine rolle spielen sollte möchte ich
jetzt wirklich sagen du bist ein mädchen
du kannst natte sollte es nicht einfach
scheiß egal sein ob du ein mädchen bist
oder nicht am besten wäre meiner meinung
nach ein geschlechtsneutrale ausdruck
und den haben wir eigentlich schon denn
das ist in der deutschen sprache der
männliche plural sollten wir nicht
lieber versuchen ein männlich
assoziierten plural wie wissenschaftler
in unseren köpfen geschlechtsneutral zu
machen im englischen ist das wort zeit
ist wirklich geschlechtsneutral und
trotzdem denken die meisten
englischsprachigen wahrscheinlich in
einen mann wenn sie das wort scientist
hören wie können wir jetzt die
wahrnehmung eines wortes in den köpfen
verändern
es ist nicht leicht aber ich sitze jetzt
hier zum beispiel vor dieser kamera und
wenn ich sage ich bin chemiker mache ich
dadurch nicht glasklar dass chemiker
auch frauen sind sowie zum
schlagabtausch
was denkt ihr aber mal was denkst du
denn jetzt ja wer aufmerksam meine
videos geschaut hat dem ist gleich
aufgefallen dass ich mich da bisher so
ein bisschen ausprobiert habe manchmal
habe ich versucht zu gendern in dem ich
so was wie wissenschaftler innen sage
meistens versuche ich beim plural
weibliche und männliche form einfach
abzuwechseln und manchmal gender ich
auch überhaupt nicht ich habe jedenfalls
noch keine elegante lösung gefunden mit
der ich zu 100 prozent zufrieden bin
aber kommen jetzt mal langsam zu euch
und zu unserem aufruf
mich nervt am meisten dass ich im jahr
2018 mehr über so was hier immer noch
gedanken machen muss dass wir überhaupt
gedanken machen muss wie ich weibliche
zuschauer erreiche war das doch
eigentlich scheißegal sein sollte
hauptsache seien es nur bei einer sache
bin ich nicht
mehr weibliche medien repräsentation in
typisch männlichen bereichen wie mild
wurde auch gängigen usw kann auf jeden
fall nicht schaden das würde ich mir
wirklich wünschen selbe gilt natürlich
auch für männer ein typisch weiblich
bereichen aber eine baustelle nach der
anderen die auch findet dass medien
repräsentation ein erster guter schritt
in die richtige richtung ist wenn die
nicht nur kommentare schreiben wollt
sondern aktiv werden wollt dann meldet
euch bei uns genauer gesagt bei folk das
geht natürlich raus an alle aber
besonders an meine ladies da draußen mit
den funk sucht dich wenn du masse
einfach wunderschön findest oder
programmieren spannender findest als
mode nichts gegen mut oder wenn du in
deiner freizeit gerne rahden baust wir
suchen mitmenschen mathe informatik
naturwissenschaften technik was für ein
herrlicher bereich mint menschen die
bock haben sich hens uns engagieren und
aktiv zu werden damit hier im netz denn
links bereich und alles was irgendwie
damit verwandt ist nicht so unnötig
stereo typisch bleibt wenn ihr lust habt
dann schreibt eine e mail an info at
funk punkt nennt mit dem betreff mit und
stellt euch vor und sagt uns was ihr
gerne ändern würde und schreibe mir wie
gesagt gerne in die kommentare
die ihr die ganze sache mit dem ländern
sieht ob ihr das auch so findet wie ich
und ich mir da einfach ein witz großkopf
mache und ja danke dass ihr bei diesem
doch recht und typischen video trotzdem
zugehört habt wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag bis dahin bleibt sicher